she's moved past the Hunger Games and
carved her own identity in The Strange
World of Hollywood here's what Willow
Shields has been up to since that
franchise wrapped when the Hunger Games
premiered in 2012 it launched the
careers of a whole new generation of
young actors stars like Jennifer
Lawrence Liam Hemsworth and Josh
Hutcherson have all gone on to lead
their own films or film franchises While
others have enjoyed steady work in
movies and TV Willow Shields who played
Katniss everdine's little sister
Primrose was cast in the role when she
was just 11 although it wasn't her first
acting role it definitely put her career
on a different trajectory May the odds
be ever in your favor getting cast in
The Hunger Games franchise got Shield's
career off to a strong start as it meant
a major role in not one but four
different films ending with The Hunger
Games Mocking Jay part two in 2015 by
the time filming wrapped Shields had
spent a third of her Young Life
portraying Prim and it was difficult to
say goodbye Shields told teen bog in
2015 there was some sadness to filming
the final two films on my last day
Jennifer Lawrence came in my tra trailer
and gave me a sweet gift and we just
hung out for a little while it was hard
because it was my last day on set and my
last shot is Prim it was all very
emotional but luckily for Shields her
career didn't die with her character
after mocking jay part two Willow
Shields followed up on that success by
becoming the youngest contestant on
Dancing With the Stars joining the
show's 20th season in 2015 before the
14-year-old landed the gig the previous
record holder had been a 16-year-old
Zena as a relative newcomer to dancing
learning and performing a new routine
each week was a challenge especially
because child labor laws mandated that
she'd take at least one day off per week
as she told Teen Vogue her prior role as
Prim added even more pressure to her
Dancing with the Stars appearances
because as she said she knew millions of
young girls looked up to her on top of
that Shields sustained multiple injuries
including a dislocated rib despite all
these difficulties Shields and her
dancing partner were one of the highest
scoring Duos during season 20 but her
good fortune ended in week seven when
her ninja themed dance routine didn't
impress fans enough to keep her around
another week sadly the odds were are no
longer in her favor but it seems like
she doesn't regret it I can't even
describe how amazing it's been it's been
an experience of a lifetime Shields has
had multiple roles in movies and TV
since the Hunger Games wrapped up her
first post Prim role was also her first
lead role in a feature film when she was
cast as Rachel in 2017's into the
rainbow a Chinese New Zealand joint
production about two girls who are
magically transported to China via a
magic rainbow the next year she landed
her first co-lead in an American feature
with the role of the rain and
woodstocker bust The Coming of Age Road
flick about two teens traveling to the
legendary 1965 Rock concert Shields has
also debted into television work with a
supporting role in the 2019 horror
series The unsettling about a
16-year-old foster child whose new home
isn't all that it seems the unsettling
lasted for one season and in 2020
Shields had another supporting role as
Serena Baker the younger sister of main
character cat Baker in the Netflix
skating series spinning out it was also
canceled after one season her next
feature role was El lead parts in the
2022 Coming of Age Indie drama when time
got louder while she was supposed to
Star alongside Tim Roth and Vincent den
aprio and the crime Thriller a Fall From
Grace from director Jennifer Lynch film
first announced in 2012 has not gone
into production to date anyone who looks
at Willow Shield's social media can see
that she keeps herself active and out in
nature part of that comes from her
dedication to climbing Shields created a
section of her Instagram called climbing
where she posts reals of her climbing up
indoor rock walls training for climbs by
doing pull-ups and the effect on on her
hands as a result of the exercise after
more than a year she eventually
progressed to climbing real Rocky
terrain outdoors and continually updates
the Instagram section as she gains more
climbing experience in one Instagram
post Shields wrote rock climbing really
brings out the badass and happiness in
me if Willow Shields isn't posting about
climbing or her passion for photography
she is definitely posting an image of
the latest book she's reading as with
climbing Shields has a section of her
Instagram dedicated to reading where she
posts particular quotes chapters and
books that she is reading most of her
books she finds in thrift stores which
she also showcases on her Instagram she
often makes individual posts about
reading on her Instagram but most of her
individual reading posts are showcased
through her second Instagram account
Willow shelf where she shares the cover
of the book the title the author the
page count and a quick review on her
caption Shields clearly feels
comfortable sharing personal details on
her social media but that went a step
further when in 2022 Shields came out
bya Instagram in June the actress posted
a picture of herself with a caption hi
I'm by happy Pride she also revealed
that she has a girlfriend in September
2023 Shields posted a few photos of them
together with a caption reminder to kiss
your girlfriend and the pride flag next
to it one friend wrote in response y all
are glowing with happiness and I love it
though Shields does not tag her
girlfriend in the post likely for
privacy reasons the two are publicly
together the Willow Shields has an
obvious love for climbing she also loves
adventuring in The Great Outdoors she is
constantly posting photos of herself
hiking through mountains spending time
in the forest and traveling to all sorts
of places out of town she captures most
of these Adventures on a vintage film
camera so I shot it all on film and then
I developed the film in my apartment so
you know I use all the chemicals and
develop it in one post Shields
documented a trip to yose with one of
her friends showing off the mountains
the hikes she went on painting in the
woods and eating ice cream with a great
view in another post Shields showed off
her trip to Alaska in another post she
and her twin Autumn can be seen in the
snow at Rocky Mountain National Park in
Colorado and in yet another Shield
shared photos of herself exploring Utah
when she's not acting Shields finds time
to pursue other creative projects and
enjoy the perks of Fame aside from being
an avid photographer climber and
Bookworm she's also a budding
passionista she first got a taste for
fashion while making appearances during
the many Hunger Games press tours and
film premieres wearing gowns and outfits
designed by some of the world's top
designers however her fashion Pursuits
didn't stop there since then Shields has
been a regular fixture at New York
Fashion Week following in the footsteps
of co-star Jennifer Lawrence in 2016 she
was the youngest front row New York
Fashion Week attendee she also worked
with La Roach an American stylist known
for his work with young celebrities such
as zanda and Ana Taylor Joy when The
Hollywood Reporter caught up with her
during nyfw in 2016 Shields described
her personal style saying it's kind of a
mix of things a lot of it is vintage I
always have loved wearing vintage
clothing I would definitely say kind of
vintage grunge but also sometimes a very
chic classic look is something that I
like to throw in Willow Shields has long
been active in charity work too she's
worked in particular to end bullying in
its many forms and is an advocate for
people to live their lives how they
please in 2011 she designed a t-shirt
for blue shirt day an anti-bullying
event organized by stomp out bullying
she's also an advocate for delete
digital drama an anti-cyberbullying
nonprofit her advocacy for anti-bullying
is also likely self-motivated as she was
under a lot of pressure and criticism to
play Prim a certain way and received her
fair share of Internet bullying in
addition to anti-bullying activism
Shields advocates for Operation Smile a
nonprofit that helps children born with
cled pallets she also works with The
Thirst project an initiative bringing
clean drinking water to impoverished
children she's aided efforts to help
victims of natural disasters provide
food for impoverished or homeless
families mitigate the effects of climate
change on forests and promote awareness
of gun violence and mass school
shootings though Willow Shields is an
avid social media user herself she can
understand firsthand the dangers and
mental damage using social media can
have in an effort to demystify the
Allure of social media and show
solidarity with those who struggle with
its expectations Shields created a photo
series and Written Letter in 2017 for a
project called dear social media which
featured diverse women sharing their
thoughts on the various pressures and
dangers of the internet as she told KTLA
I've shot a series of photos that I've
kind of titled women warriors and a lot
of it is about just celebrating the
beauty and diversity of all women the
project premiered at BeautyCon La in
2017 with a feminist photography
featuring model iscra Lawrence and actor
Tracy Ellis Ross though this was an
outlet of creativity for Shields and
also matches or activist Pursuits
including Shields involvement in the
March for our lives and the women's
March in talking with teen bog about the
Project Shield said it's really
important that we make light of the
issues women face on social media not
just by recognizing it but by
transforming it into an important
interesting issue my goal is to do this
through
[Music]
ART